[Applause]
[Music]
so I've been playing a lot of Soul
Calibur six since I came out and by
playing I mean getting destroyed by you
our resident fighting game fan
especially since you did the review I'm
gonna call that unfair advantage foul to
me but we're gonna talk about Soul
Calibur six vs Tekken 7
what's more accessible what's gonna give
you the most bang for your buck and if
you're like a solid fighting game fan
what's gonna allow you to get to those
high levels you're starting off with
Soul Calibur obviously you played it for
the review how do you how did you feel
like jumping back into it how did you
feel like it's accessibility is it's the
thing about Soul Calibur is it's them
seems to be the most appealing fighting
game and a lot always like a lot of them
have history and stuff but I think it's
a lot of it and more wrapped up in
nostalgia than most people remember it
to be like they think back to soul
calibur to which it feels like one of
those fighting games that everyone
played when they see Soul Calibur again
they the more inclined to give it a shot
and from that respect I think it's very
approachable
it's got complicated systems but what I
said in my review which you can read on
Gamescom now is that it's a pickup and
playable game more so than any other
fighting game yeah you're looking at
characters and you're like what weapon
do I want am I most interested in you
don't even have to think about the
character you don't need to worry that
nightmare is a giant evil Knight you're
just like that dude's got a massive
sword a big eyeball yeah so like on that
level it's immediately like welcoming to
you you you're thinking about the weapon
you want to use the thing about I'll
carry with us always especially this one
is it's got systems but unlike other
fighting games you'd not prevent it you
don't feel like you're missing out on a
piece of the puzzle you start pressing
buttons and it feels like you're good at
the game just because the feedback you
get and what's going on with this you
start pressing buttons you're good you
feel alright you feel like you're
getting better and if you're not it's
kind of like playing rock-paper-scissors
but you're moving so fast that you're
having fun in the moment yeah and before
you know it like you might have lost the
game but you're back in it straightaway
and you're just hitting buttons again
and maybe you'll win this time and it
will be fun that's that's what a fight
for me as a much more casual fighting
game fan for a fighting game to like a
lock it's closing to me it needs to be
immediately rewarding like a sound
shallow but when I pick up the game I
want to be able to feel that within an
hour I can do stuff that looks cool and
that was much easier to do in Soul
Calibur than it was in Tekken
[Music]
like I was playing the story mode in
Tekken 7 and I was getting destroyed by
like the AI hmm from the outset and it
felt really hard to do cool stuff and
and Tekken has the assist system to
allow you to where we hold the l1 and
press a face button to do a cool move
instead of inputting the whole combo but
even through that I felt like quite like
it was very like analog I think it was
just a series of punches that didn't
seem connected to each other it seemed
very basic and that it took a lot more
it took a lot longer to actually feel
like I was doing cool stuff in that
fighting game yeah so Tekken is more
combo based and more like which moves do
you chained together in succession at
what moments at what level is that what
like direction is that kind of stuff so
our caliber is similar but it's got a
more limited move set there are combos
but it's more about picking the move in
the right situation and then thinking
about how to react your opponent
I feel solid Calibre's got much more
focus on on movement so if someone's
training together vertical attacks you
can just you can just sidestepping and
again for me playing that and
immediately be rewarded if it's like hey
the game acknowledges you're getting
better
and you're doing all this cool [ __ ] to
show for it so I thought about is
definitely the more approachable and
gently fun under sense because I won
more games and got absolutely destroyed
and take the whole defying games Tekken
has always been the one known for its
story mainly because they get really
goofy with it you know that you have
that thing where you know here hacci
throws because they're into a volcano
and that kind of stuff they all have
really goofy starts and ends but this
year out of these two games Soul Calibur
actually beats Tekken in terms of the
story offerings it has it's got two
story modes tell caribou Double Down the
story modes and goes we've got all the
stories so much story got all of it so
it's got libre of souls which is a
classic like throwback to an older Soul
Calibur to where you explore a world and
you do like you know fighting and you do
little RPG stuff and there's the other
mode which is a more specific chronicle
of soul mode where it's about every
characters got a story and then the oh
there's an overarching story so I think
that's one of the strongest parts of
Soul Calibur but you mentioned Tekken I
I play tried to play the Tekken story
mode and I was just what's going on
I had she's assaulting a base led by
Nina it's like I'm like I'd lost that's
Tekken game I play he started the game
is like a robot girl again I was just
lost
hmm I'm not saying you need to need to
know the law of chacón but it was it was
kind of presented in a way that it was
also kind of unsatisfying to me but then
it's playing Soul Calibur making my own
goofy character giving him new few
weapons and going through Li lever of
souls and kind of going to where you
want it's a little dialogue heavy and I
will admit when I was playing that hands
like why don't you just want to fight
folk I skipping it yeah so I think I
think Tekken story mode is definitely
it's got a lot of the feel like I enjoy
Tekken
story mode if you enjoyed second story
mode because I history yeah I have the
history so for people who have been
following along with it
it's it's enjoyable and it's it's got
the Winx and the nods and there's a
really dumb storyline that has been
going on from the first game and back
and forth and you can carry on that
storyline but if you're like a new
player who just wants to sit down with a
story and kind of aura a game and have
kind of a story Sakai burr is definitely
better and although Libra is very very
text heavy if you go into Libra Souls
knowing this is gonna be a very like
text heavy voice heavy kind of like
exploration mode with fights in there
you have a better overall experience and
you get to meet like different
characters and go on a like an epic
adventure is what I call it
but one thing I found really good about
Soul Calibur this is the holistic kind
of a series is it kind of restarts the
story each time it's like you have the
intro of like what soul edges and the
world starts to go to pot and then X
character will go Mayan soul edge so
it's immediately accessible you can just
jump in as like I want to fight
servantes and get the magic sword and
its own it's got like Geralt stories in
there yeah and it's pretty good it's
very it's very girl like you Falls for
report ones like what the hell is going
on well easily the best Soul Calibur
character Titan yeah the entire
franchise yeah yeah he's just confused
and and like why is everyone trying to
fight me and then he's like I need to
just get out of here cuz it's freaking
me out
come take me on crap like this and he
hates portals as we all know and this is
kind of frustrating him so it's fun to
see him in that world but like the
overall story with Killick and Shanghai
is there and everyone else has got the
individual story so it's a meeting me
experience but Tekken has bowling it
does have bowling I didn't want to talk
about bowling because it's it's it's
shocking how much work they've put into
bowling I love how much work they put
into bowling but why because Tekken
always has one weird mode and I love the
fact that they have that mode when it
comes Tekken I'm like the dad from
Malcolm in the Middle
I'm obsessed with the bowling I need to
be there I've got a routine stop it it's
weird seeing Yoshimitsu trembles
[Applause]
seeing like fine games come and go and
seeing how Tekken's acted and how Soul
Calibur is in its early days where do
you see the game is going for like the
hard the person who really wants to get
into the competitive scene and how the
competitive scene is now I think both
games can coexist
and they will coexist for a little while
in the community and both games can be
enjoyed on various levels I think in
terms of complexity and and kind of like
really trying to climb the ladder Tekken
is the one that I would lean towards
because there's more competition there
right now there's more in terms of like
game design it's a trickier game to beat
good at it's it requires it's like
walking uphill basically it's an uphill
struggle to be good at a game and if
you're a fighting game player like a lot
of the value of a fighting game is in
that like that kind of the grind of it
figuring it out and being like I've
cracked a character I know how to play
his character I'll come over strategy I
have these combos down I can read and
you get a lot of that in Tekken and the
Soul Calibur is also very very like a
fun game that has depth to it right now
the thing that the one thing that I
struggle with in whistle caliber is it
is complicated it has depth but also has
ways for people who don't want to engage
with that depth to also be quite
competent at it
when you're kind of like looking at a
unlike a fundamental level like some of
these systems clash with each other and
it means that they're like for example
the the rock-paper-scissors system yes a
bit random like and that kind of turns
me off
I think kaqun for me is just I really
like hitting buttons that's the thing
like I said like I'm one of those people
that wants to be piano inky's constantly
and techie let those buttons like I told
you money they owe me money all the time
but like so that that that element of
Tekken is really satisfying to me like
always being active and doing something
the frantic part of Soul Calibur feels
like it's it's movement its your
movement focus with the eighth wave
running system and I put I prefer that
and having my attacks more measured and
like talking about playing it a
competitive level
I've tried ranked on both games in the
past few days and what's been nice about
Soul Calibur is because I'm not like a
fighting game pro I'm learning the game
alongside the community so I can enter
ranked yeah and hold my own with the two
characters that I actually know whereas
I went into Tackett and like out take
the two or three characters I know and I
got like absolutely pure just destroyed
epochal it to be a triple perfect for a
casual player I think that the like
building a skill base is much easier for
Soul Calibur
so what I really like about Soul Calibur
and why I think they can coexist is so
I'll color book can be used as like a
gateway flying game and that's what I
really really like about it like you can
get into it and play the game and feel
good about playing or fighting game
that's the trickiest part of the
fighting game like when you start
playing one if you don't if you're not
having fun like you don't feel inclined
to dig deeper and figure that stuff out
so what kind of I will let you have fun
from the outset because it's so
intuitive the fundamentals of it you'll
start thinking about the nuances a
little more and once you've kind of
figured it out and you feel comfortable
with Soul Calibur eventually you reach
the point where you like what else can I
do with these skills are they
transferable they are transferable a lot
of those skills are transferable and you
can take them to something like Tekken I
think that as a game Soul Calibur is
really good for being the entry point
the Tekken is maybe the next step after
that if you wanted to complicate it a
little more so hardcore players are
probably going to feel better overtaken
but like I would recommend everyone play
so caliber especially if you're and you
come and you always wanted to be good at
buying game and play a fine game and
enjoy it
so as you were saying you briefly
touched on it if for me at least it
feels like if you've got the fighting
game chops already and you want a new
challenge and you haven't played Tekken
then Tekken's like you want for you but
if you're like me a more casual game
fighting fan you want to your skills to
improve and grow alongside the community
Soul Calibur right now feels like a
really good time you have to start
playing like get in while the going is
hot like be a part of community learn
alongside everyone else for me Soul
Calibur has grabbed me much more than my
experience with protec yeah if you're
100 percent new my recommendation is to
pick up Soul Calibur and jump into libro
soul's Libre ourselves the first few
missions are a training kind of like
sweet you'll be able to have that that
kind of like journey where you're
learning what not to do as well as what
to do alongside other people who are
also doing it you're going to try and do
it with Tekken and you'll get wall
bounced and ground bounce then you know
pull drived and juggled and like smashed
around very very quickly it's a good
welcoming fighting game learning sweet
right now and then you can like
diversify your bonds and and go and you
know two different other fighting game
invested industry that was a hot Dave
Chapelle reference Oh wu-tang clan rep
well if you want to hear more about Soul
Calibur without wu-tang clan references
unfortunately you can you can read
tomorrow's review and let us know what
you think of the 2 games on Twitter
I'm a regular Dave and more H and the
thing I really want to know is which
Pioche emissions you prefer I prefer
attackers space octopus or soul calibers
cool ninja yeah I saw a kind of a school
ninja is easily the best for easily you
know yeah definitely but nightmare is
the best character which we go I see an
exit a fire
[Music]